in this talk i will introduce my result
on the complexity of confidence's pd
and ccp is the constraint satisfaction
problem
and now let's start with the definition
of content cssp
consider building formula 5 it has two
classes
and now we we can use two boolean
functions to express in the formula
the f and gp2 tender reporting functions
f takes no value one if and only if in
the clause
x1 or x2 or x3 is true
and the function g is obtained by
three pin the third variable of function
f
now we say the formula 5 defines a
function f
phi it's the product of f and g
applied on the variables of the two
clauses
respectively
clearly the formula 5 is
satisfiable if and only if the function
f5 is not identically zero
in this talk we care about counting
problems that is
the number of satisfied assignments for
phi
this is the example showing that we can
use
functions to express constrain of
various constraints in fact
to express the weighted constraints we
can
allow the functions to be real or
complex value
when we talk about the functions we
always fix
a finite domain d and the function of
array decay
is a math from d to the k to the complex
numbers
now we define the content csp and
they have this final set of functions
we denote the following problem by
chassis
contentious pf
an instance i have has
n variables and m constraints
each constraint is a function f
is a function from f applied on a tuple
of variables
and these variables are not necessarily
different
now we say the instance defines a
function f
i it's the product of all
these constraints
and the output of this problem is
the partition function is the sum
over all variable some assignments
intuitively if you want to compute such
a sound
the structure
the function of i must have a very nice
structure
in fact 2 yes in fact to this go we need
to consider more functions
uh given the function f of average n
and for each t we define f t
to be the function obtained by doing the
summation
of variables from
x t plus 1 to x n
[Music]
and now for the function set f we can
define
this wf it contains all the function
of t well f is a
function defined by some instances
of some instance of cspf
dichotomy theorem for
contentious pdf
that is for for any function set f
the problem spf justice is in polynomial
time
if if wf satisfies three conditions
otherwise the problems should be hard
here we do not
to we do not need to introduce nursery
conditions
in fact they are a little complicated
roughly speaking the three conditions
will require every function
in the set wf to be
well structured such that
there is a algorithm to compute the
partition function
efficiently
in fact even if the problem is shopping
hard
it's still possible that the algorithm
may succeed
on the non-trivial subset
of instances
now introduce now we introduce
cspd here d is a positive
integer
the problem counting says ptf is the
restriction
of contingencies p to the instances
where
each variable occurs a multiple of d
times
inspired by the result of a
sine n chain i proper dichotomy theorem
for
convinces pd the three conditions
remain unchanged but now they are
imposed
and they are imposed on the cw wfd
because now we are we only interested in
the cspd instances
and this is yes this is this series
unifies the economic student from the
whole assist pt
family and personally i think it's
very beautiful
so be honest why why we need to consider
contingencies pd and in fact
it they naturally arise in the study of
a more general framework called holland
province
and we know that csp is going
it is able to express a wide range of
graph parameters and many other
important problems but
the problems like graph matching do not
fit
in the csp framework
now we consider the matching problem uh
given graph g a subset of edges is a
matching if
each vertex has almost one incident
edge in the set
so an edge is in or not in a matching so
they can be
viewed as as boolean variables
a vertex can be viewed as a boolean
function
the function takes the value 1 if
m is the one instant edge is not 0.
in csp we allow variables to appear
arbitrary many times right but
to express the matching problem we only
need
the instances where each each variable
appears exactly twice
and that is the definition of holding
problems
by definition the net
and counting the number of matchings
is exactly a quantum carbon
uh for function set f
clearly called f is necessary problem of
the problem says pf but
in the same time we can express
confidence p
by adding a
[Music]
eq function
the function eq the function eq is used
to simulate
the variables in constrained
satisfaction
so the whole framework is more
expressive
and then we would like to ask
the complexity of holland problems
in fact data conversion for home
problems
remains open even on the boolean domain
here we on the point domain means
the functions oh sorry
the functions that define under apply
on boolean variables
quantum problems has have been
intensively studied
for many years and there are some
important results
uh very recently shaw anti-approved
dichotomy serum from the
for the real uh holding progress
but in the complex bundle the case for
complex ways is still open
in common problems complex numbers
give rise to many interesting and
surprising algorithms
also the connections between some
problems require complex linear
transformations
an interesting phenomenon is this
list that can be syrians
all requires a reduction from constant
csp
location spd
in fact sometimes it's easy to reduce
from the condenser spd
sometimes we need to reduce from some
other problems like
matchings so it's very important to
understand the complexity of complex spd
and this is the motivation of
this work
uh i just
introduced uh the economy theorem for
companies spd on general domains
before the result and in fact there are
only
in the community series on the boarding
domain
when a new proof dichotomy
for symmetric functions the function is
actually if if it's invalid
it's invariant under the permutation of
variables
and recently chi lu and xia
prove dichotomy for csp2
think this i think this result is
important
lay the foundation for all recent
progress
on quality problems and the third result
is
it's about yes
it's on cspd but they assume that
we can always flip in the variables of a
function
to produce new functions
and these diagonals this dichotomous
series
failed to classify all function cells
but
they are explicit
for example let's see the dichotomy
theorem for
for content csp and
csp2
the criteria are explicit so given a
function
set f you can decide quickly
whether the problem is in polynomial
time
or not also note that
the csp2 dichotomy
has two more checkable classes
the proof of this dichotomy is
complicated
because the functions in the class
error has intricate structures
in my opinion i'd be i think it would be
more difficult to derive
such criteria for general
for contingencies pd
so can we
prove that dichotomy in in other ways
of course now we have the dichotomy for
the general domains but
it's too general to say much about the
bullying domain
we may try to simply find the three
conditions
but there is
a direct generalization of the first
theorem
yes
um for any function set f
uh here here we all these functions are
are all on the boolean domain since ptf
is shaping hardness and every function
in type fd
is product type or every function in wfd
is a phi
this is a dichotomy for the whole assist
cspd
family it shows that is essentially
there are
only two checkable classes in the class
the class error and the class af
disappeared yes in in
in the in the foreign dichotomy
the same one is very different from csp2
and very different from the
existing economies for horn problems
by the way the proof is very simple
of course it is built on the ssp
that can be
now it comes to proof
fact the techniques are very simple and
standard
the key point is to realize that we can
do the classification in a different
level or in a different
perspective and
in the following i will talk about the
proof of the dichotomy of general
domains
uh firstly we consider the algorithmic
part
we didn't know the algorithm for
contentious p by a
an important observation is given a cspd
instance i the algorithms are
the opposite a starts with the
function fi and it only operates on the
functions
in wfd
the algorithm may produce new functions
by
summing over some variables of a
function
or just permuting the variables
well
the wfd is closed is closed
under such operations
the first is for under the follows from
the definition of
f wfd and the second
is follow from the definition of
continue csp in fact
for instance i if you confuse
the variables then you in fact
you actually you are confusing the
variables of
the function
so under the three conditions
every function in wf these
were structures so
so the algorithm succeeds
and and this is the
checkability part
now we can see in the hardness part
um we say that
the set wft wireless the three
conditions if
there is a financial g in
subset g wireless any of them
now to prove the hardness we suppose
yes there is such a g
and by the
final result of
of science and they prove
yes cspg contagious pg
in fact it's shaping hard
and the hardness of competencies spill
flow
flows from a standard reduction from
contact p to
d and
we complete we complete and prove
[Music]
thanks